então de novo bom dia e eu queria
convidar vocês nesses próximos 18
minutos pra gente falar de tecnologias
de impacto e pra mim falar de tecnologia
de impacto requer duas coisas a primeira
é construir e reconstruir alguns
conceitos que é o que vou tentar fazer
com vocês aqui ea segunda é realizar a
gente está vivendo um momento muito
especial da história do homem mas neste
planeta
meus amigos aqui the singularity
conhecem bem essa frase do piraí a mãe
diz que toda vez que ele comece uma
palestra ele fala que está vivendo
tempos extraordinários que ele está
falando com isso e que eu concordo que
ele está vivendo um momento da
humanidade que essas tecnologias que têm
invadido as nossas vidas como smartphone
que mudou o mundo aí nos últimos dez
anos ou a própria internet estão mudando
a nossa forma de se organizar no mundo
enquanto a sociedade não sabe o impacto
delas para o futuro necessariamente mas
não há como negar que essas mudanças têm
o mesmo impacto ou pelo menos algo
parecido como o que a gente viveu na
revolução agrícola e o que a gente viveu
na revolução industrial
entendo que não está nesse contexto é
disso que eu quero falar hoje pra vocês
mas eu me apresentar melhor eu sou
mariana fonseca
sou mineira de belo horizonte eu acho
que a história mais divertida que eu
tenho pra contar pra vocês na minha
infância é que quando eu era pequena eu
tinha um medo muito particular
eu acordava chorando à noite com medo do
infinito
não sei se mais não pra minha mãe o que
era a criança chorando na cama e ela
chegava inclusive ela taxistas podem
perguntar pra ela ela muito com medo
angústia com medo do infinito ela não
podia olhar debaixo da cama falar olha
minha filha não tem bicho papão
olha minha filha vou acender a luz se
vai ver que não tem assaltante
minha filha vai abrir o armário não tem
um monstro ela tinha que lidar com a
minha angústia extremamente humana de
ter medo do infinito e medo do infinito
é muito humano porque essa nossa
capacidade de entender ou tentarem
vender um conceito extremamente abstrato
como infinito é extremamente humano
vai ver o chipanzé discutindo infinito
ele pode discutir acasalamento pode
discutir alimentos mas ele não vai
discutir infinito
essa capacidade de acordos abstratas e
complexas uma capacidade humana mas da
mesma forma que a gente cria esses
conceitos estão me pode desconstruir
esses conceitos e foi um pouco do que
foi fazendo ao longo da minha vida
o primeiro conceito que eu tive que
desconstruir foi de jornalismo eu fiz
jornalismo porque achava que eu ia mudar
o mundo
eu achava que como jornalista
descobrindo as mazelas do mundo e
mostrando isso marcaria da sociedade que
eu e motivar as pessoas a melhorar o
mundo e obviamente com poucos danos de
redação me frustrei muito por descobrir
que essa coisa do jornalismo de varoto
valorizar o problema né valorizar aquele
jornalista que acham furo de reportagem
que vai destruir a vida de alguém que é
um escândalo
serve para alguma coisa é importante mas
não era pra mim porque eu não queria
falar do problema incomodava saber o
problema e fala aí eu faço com isso
então eu comecei a me envolver no
paralelo na minha vida com pessoas e
projectos que estavam tentando apontar
caminhos
ok a gente entendeu que tem problema a
gente quer tentar resolver então eu fui
fazer a corrente do bem no brasil com
dois amigos
a primeira até 10 são paulo aqui no
brasil foi em 2009 se não me engano foi
coop cobrir como jornalista
enfim fui me envolvendo em projetos
paralelos para provar que dava para o
jornalista também querem saber de
solução e não só o problema e até que
caiu no meu colo de presente um projeto
que chama por vir ponto org que eu fui
ajudei a criar e foi editor chefe e é
uma plataforma que mapeia inovação e
educação no brasil e no mundo
eu vou ouvir tava todos os dias buscando
tecnologias pessoas metodologias
professores escolas gente que tinha
entendido que a educação no super
problema mas que estava tentando
resolver esse problema e eu me vi como
jornalista pela primeira vez na vida
dando
boas notícias todos os dias foi incrível
para mim só que claro se estava mapeando
inovação e educação
eu tive que rever o conceito de educação
eu me formei escola católica em minas e
eu estudei na frança
naqueles anfiteatros gelados como aqui e
que tinha um professor que era deus a
gente ficava três horas anotando não
podia fazer pergunta e aí é uma prova
que eu tinha que resolver essa prova
provável que eu sabia alguma coisa
esse primeiro educação e aí de repente
eu comecei a conviver com escola árvore
escola baseado em games escola que não
tinha professor escola que não tinha
disciplina escola que não tinha prova
escola que nem era escola cidade quer
escola tudo online enfim eu comecei a
descobrir que a educação tem muito menos
a ver com o formato ou a ferramenta e
muito mais como eu aprendo e como eu vou
resolvendo meus problemas dos problemas
do mundo e aí eu passei muito tempo com
esse projeto é mentor ano startup
sedetec viajando o brasil falando de
inovação educação e tecnologias da
educação me senti um pouco incomodada
eu mesmo nunca ter vivido essa educação
que o pregava tanto
e foi aí que eu me inscrevi para a
singularity university
eu tenho alguns colegas aqui que
estudaram comigo lá se vão conhecer hoje
é e pra quem não conhece a singularity a
universidade que fica no vale do silício
no parque de pesquisa da nasa que está
olhando todas as tecnologias que vão
mudar o mundo nos próximos anos
e todos os problemas do mundo ainda tem
como educação saúde meio ambiente e
energia
enfim bota problema para a gente
resolver ea ideia como isso pode
conversar como que as tecnologias podem
conversar com os problemas mas é claro
seu filho em uma universidade que é
conhecida por tecnologia de ponta e por
futurismo
eu também tive que rever o conceito
porque eu achava e tecnologia e futuro
tinha muito mais a ver com esses robôs
da serra da ficção científica que o
dominar o mundo que eu
subjugar o homem que eles eram super
malvados e perversa
essa era a minha leitura em consciente
ou super consciente de tecnologia e de
cara eu descobri que não que tecnologia
é uma ferramenta para resolver o
problema e tecnologia podia ser uma
tinta de parede que estava absorvendo a
luz solar e gerar energia para uma casa
a tecnologia podia ser um novo robô que
eu vou injetar na minha corrente
sanguínea e ele vai buscar nas células
cancerígenas tecnologia podia ser um
computador quântico que vai ocupar uma
sala dessa e que vai processar dados
antes nunca vista
isto terá tecnologia e o mais legal é
que eu descobri que tecnologia podia ser
uma coisa extremamente simples para
resolver um problema complexo
então hoje a gente acha super normal
gravar vídeos pelo celular ea gente tem
que considerar a capacidade de gravar
vídeo aulas no celular
e essas vídeo-aulas chegarem para a
filha de bill gates ou por uma menina no
interior rural do quênia para ajudar a
resolver o problema da educação
por outro lado a tecnologia também pode
ser uma coisa extremamente complexa como
um grid de armazenar energia enfim
energia solar e alimentar e produzir
para fazer alguma coisa com isso eo a
uma usando uma coisa que na verdade é um
problema que o nosso corpo às plantas os
animais já resolveram anos
há séculos que é usar energia solar como
fonte de energia
só que claro você também estava numa
faculdade de futurismo
eu tive que rever o conceito de futuro
até então eu achava que o futuro era
andar de carro do google não tem
motorista é meio jackson assim tem uma
secretária e roubou enfim isso pra mim
era o futuro e quanto mais eu fui
estudando entendendo futuro
eu entendi que ele estava falando de
seres humanos porque se a gente vai ter
a tecnologia de ponta para aumentar
nossa longevidade está falando de viver
300 anos ou mais
estou falando de ver 300 anos todos
nossa ou só parte da sociedade e gerar
mais um game social mais igualdade
social
você está falando dessas super
tecnologias dos martírios marca rony
smarth qualquer coisa a gente tá falando
disso para qualquer pessoa
a obra uma parte privilegiada da
sociedade ea gente precisa pensar falar
de futuro falar de tecnologia falar de
ética é falar de valores é repensar essa
sociedade
isso daria um telex inteiro mas enfim
acho que a mensagem que mais me motivou
a fazer alguma coisa quando eu voltei de
lá foi uma surpresa eu descobri que
tinha gente usando tecnologia de ponta
em super inovação em sua inovação
antecipando problemas do futuro e
ganhando dinheiro com isso a pena mudar
dá pra fazer de tudo pra fazer isso todo
esse conceito ainda é muito novo no
brasil a gente tem pouco mais de 10 anos
que a gente fala de negócios de impacto
ou negócios sociais
o empreendedorismo social lá fora tem um
pouco mais de tempo mas também é novo
essa ideia e assim tem várias formas de
definir o negócio de impacto mas a mais
comum vem da idéia de pegar toda a
expertise o profissionalismo do setor da
indústria e dos serviços setor
secundário e unir com a capacidade de
entender um problema de endereçar um
problema social profundo que as ongs
institutos fundações do setor terciário
tem isso é a forma mais simples de
definir negócios sociais o negócio de
impacto mas claro que estou falando de
tecnologia e futurismo
eu não faço só essa conta setor 2 mas
setor 3 é igual a dois e meio ele é
chamado o setor dois e meio para quem
conhece ou não conhece o setor de
negócios impacto fica no setor dois e
meio mas eu acho que dá pra um pouco
mais de sabor nessa conversa porque além
do profissionalismo da capacidade de
escalar e de ganhar dinheiro do business
do setor 2 e da capacidade de resolver
problemas de entender o problema do
setor 3
a gente também está falando de hackers e
cientistas malucos que estão criando
inovação e ter uma idéia todos os dias
no laboratório experimentando na garagem
de casa e quando a gente mistura todo
mundo
dá uma startup genial de impacto
vocês vão conhecer algumas aqui hoje
isso pra mim é o a falar no melhor
momento de um negócio de impacto e não
sou só eu que estou falando de um
negócio de impacto
o bill gates fala muito e ele precisou
ser o homem mais rico do mundo pra hoje
largar tudo isso trabalha na fundação
esse é o homem que mais investe no
problema no mundo
ele é a pessoa que mais investe em
educação por exemplo no mundo hoje aqui
no brasil recentemente no seu sangue é
da inde vôo
o guilherme leal também falou disso ele
falou que ele vem de uma geração em que
ele precisava ter uma empresa dessa
empresa acrescenta que a empresa
precisava ganhar dinheiro e quando ela
dava certo
ele agora eu vou criar um instituto uma
fundação para resolver os problemas que
ficaram no caminho
e aí a alegria dele aqui por sorte a
minha geração ea geração mais nova já
entende um pouco mais o conceito de
empreendedorismo social já acha que dá
pra nascer resolvendo um problema e além
de resolver um problema não deixando
resíduos não deixando outros problemas
pelo caminho
essa é outra forma de definir negócios
sociais ou negócio de impacto
quando eu voltei da singularity pela
segunda vez feliz
eu e meu sócio do instituto aula seu
camarim pois é uma empresa de rhodolfo o
instituto inspirar essa pesquisa que era
empreendedores de impacto as dores e as
delícias de novo à educação
a gente passou seis meses falando com
empreendedores ad tech dos mais
diferentes regiões do país para entender
como era resolver um problema profundo
desse país que a educação é trabalhar
com inovação e tecnologia e ainda tentar
ganhar dinheiro com isso e foi super
interessante ver que no fundo já existe
esse movimento no brasil e que talvez
fora do eixo rio-são paulo que já
entendem um pouco desse universo de
impacto
as pessoas ainda não sabiam que você
poderia diferenciar a sua startup das
demais estar tapes se você interessava
uma causa porque porque quando você está
tratando de uma causa tão latente no
país como educação
você tem muita gente querendo ajudar
você tem dinheiro só para impacto se têm
fundações e institutos querendo te
ajudar a dar certo tem mentores que
jamais teria sua startup não tivesse
impacto ea gente se incomodava já só que
essas pessoas precisavam saber disso ea
incomodados com isso eu e minhas duas
amigas criamos a mais um pouco mais de
dois meses a partir do ponto social que
além das milhares de coisas que a parte
que é ser ela quer ser uma vitrine de
negócios de impacto
a gente quer achar pelo brasil quem está
resolvendo o problema e quer tentar
ganhar dinheiro com isso trabalhando com
inovação e que precisa de ajuda
então a gente está falando de problemas
em saúde educação meio ambiente
cidadania energia água mobilidade urbana
no falta o problema do nosso país até o
dia da mães brinca você quer ganhar 1
bilhão de dólares
resolve o problema de um bilhão de
pessoas é uma boa forma de ficar rico
mas aí o mais legal talvez o que eu
venho percebendo que tem muito a ver com
que a gente acabou de ouvir é que esses
empreendedores hoje a gente tem quase
200 empreendedores cadastrados na apae
pi fora os 50 que já tinha conversado
a gente descobriu que os empreendedores
estão revendo um outro conceito que o
conceito de trabalho porque trabalho já
foi da carreira sólida ganhar dinheiro
né
fica ali a trabalhar separado da vida
pessoal
há muito tempo para muitas gerações
trabalho para outras pessoas era a
porque eu sou bom nisso eu vou fazer
isso e para a minha geração algumas
pessoas desses empreendedores que a
gente conversou e muitos jovens que
estão chegando
o trabalho também com o propósito eu
passo pelo menos oito horas do meu dia
meu trabalho para muita gente o que você
faz o seu trabalho é um é possível que
seu legado para o mundo que vai deixar
esse mundo e pra muita gente
o trabalho vai determinar as pessoas que
você vai conhecer os lugares que você
vai viajar
os livros que você vai ler tudo está
muito ligado ao seu trabalho
e aí quando você vai ter um negócio
a mesma pergunta se imagina que vai
passar
empreendedores de plantão sabem que oito
horas é brincadeira o empreendedor passa
muito mais tempo criando um negócio a
negócio do papel e tocando o negócio mas
imagina você tirar do papel tocar um
negócio a negócio ainda não tem
propósito não fazer sentido com a sua
vida só servir pra você ganhar dinheiro
então eu faço vou fazer uma pergunta eu
faço essa pergunta pra todos os
empreendedores a primeira pergunta que a
gente faz
eles vão ficar lá só na apae pi e eu
queria fazer essa pergunta pra vocês
hoje
qual é o problema de um negócio de vocês
resolve no mundo
é isso gente brigada